hey there I got out of the way I'm not
doing it again the joke that we got it
we got asked at the last convention
where I am what is your least favorite
joke I think mine was timing it is so
fucking annoying
every time I think of something that
annoys me I'm in the South's critic that
instantly swings mine just timing shut
up killed it off for a reason
um but it's a ghost okay everyone ever
really died okay so this is a real
photon Casper um the hell do you even
make it no yeah I got another film this
is no film that tries way too hard like
I'm gonna write this whole story around
this is gonna be like would be like a
little romance exhibit I'm like you know
this is a cartoon meant for
four-year-olds you probably could have
coughed anything up no honestly I don't
dislike this movie as much as I probably
lit on in the review I mean even the
review I don't think I hate it and or
anything like that but I think it was
something weird this is one CG uh we
just talked about Jurassic Park um you
know we had the mask that was like you
know sort of doing these cartoony things
and then this was kind of the first time
they did CG with like full characters
like happy your cast was
computer-generated working with people
and they're transparent you can see
through can you make people feel things
for them and stuff like that and you can
uh it just doesn't always happen in this
and the the fight thing is I there's a
lot of respect in this movie cuz thing
Casper the movie how fucking good can
this be probably not very great how bad
could it be it could be like the worst
shit you could see uh and I don't think
it's actually that but it's a decent
effort see um if it were the this falls
in my theory if it were the worst shit
it could possibly be at least maybe be
hilariously awful this movie for me is
just mad see I chose it all the whole
way through man no see I give it credit
that it at least tried to do because
it's kind of a risk with something like
this how do you take these
computer-generated character Casper
probably the most dorky cartoon you
could bring to life at that time and
actually make the you know kind of
likable kind of relatable kind of cute
have a relationship you know but inside
this dark cool mansion and stuff like
that you know like that ass
like I would have liked this come a lot
more if it was just the relationship
between Casper the girl and the whatever
the cousins were or whatever they are um
when you throw in the treasure chest and
trying to find the inheritance and there
the lost gold and the machine that can
bring people back it's it's not needed
this would have been fine if it was just
their connection you know she goes to
school you know talks about how it's
going maybe they use the ghostly powers
to get revenge on the kid or something
like that they find out something else
or maybe it's getting along with the
cousins you know that would have been
fine but I think back then that just
that would have flown they were like
well we're kids movies and we think kids
are idiot still and we're not gonna make
really good kids movies until Pixar
comes along so we had to throw in all
these extra plot elements that are
needed
Wow you thought way more about the
master than I ever but no you know what
cuz when I saw this film I was really
ready to hate it but I'm still kind of
intrigued because like I say I just
hadn't seen the CG creations yet and
sort of this cool Tales from the Crypt
looking house so I was a little
intrigued to see it but I was ready to
hate it I was shocked I did not totally
hate it but I didn't actually think it
was goody I was ready to hate it and
then instead got bored by it and fell
asleep literally I think I fell asleep
in the cinema when I saw it for the
first time I think it here here's my
thought if I'm a director and I'm given
uh your next movie is Casper like the
ghost yeah and you got to make him cool
you know how the hell do you do this and
I could so easily seal the end for
weapon no no my cannon so easily see
this going to like what was that dog the
Homer Simpson voiced in the poochy
poochy I get everything okay I will give
you this it was the MIT was it the
mid-90s that film came out yeah it was
the mid-90s and they could have gone
extreme with Casper and they didn't so
they didn't putrefy it but they also do
a lot of like the pop cultural
references the really pointless swearing
which I'm not really that hard against
worry because I wrote it
this is Aladdin I think kind of rekt
films for at least as much as I love the
Aladdin
like that one did it right and then so
many like kids just wanted to be a lad
not I was like we FG it but cultural
references man is gonna be funny this is
another one where it's like odd Jesus um
but I think it's the fact that they keep
Casper I mean like they they talk about
how Casper died he'd I mean it's like I
kind of give this movie credit for doing
these things that I at the time I would
not expect a Casper the Friendly Ghost
movie to do but it didn't work though I
know that's the thing I'm assuming it
stories about that take it serious give
you why you could take this here no I'm
like now we're going to talk about how
the ghost died in the first place like I
just couldn't because the rest of the
movie doesn't support that scene some
scenes do like si but the relationship
is her and when I read it in the house I
thought there's too much shit going on
like you you either would have had to
have done this seriously or like cut out
the read just you can't mesh all those
things together like either make it for
kids and make it the stupid sequel Wendy
or windy or whatever or try to do it
seriously but like trying to combine
both of organ of the Ghostbusters in
this one and we're resentment
yeah they had another side we're gonna
Ghostbuster in this one and I am friggin
intercom easy we're gonna blow home and
as the father turns in the ghost it
doesn't matter but now we're gonna have
a serious moment and a tween romance
with a ghost
what fuck are you know see I can I have
you thought that stuff for the most part
worked okay
oh well I'll tell you this then you
should go talk christina ricci because I
remember her in interviews being like
yeah I movie sucked
no no I she's like this movie I remember
reading this interview and she's like
this movie makes no sense I'm supposed
to be in love with the ghost how does
this work cuz it's like a cartoon for
pardon then these alone
no no no the interview I really want to
hear is Bill Pullman because you know
that guy is just like after mudgin age
everything is I got the fuck I'm doing
this movie but Richie sort of turned
into that too though so - so well from
what I hear I don't know she could be
great
uhm but dicey
holman on interviews and when he's live
and stuff like that he he does not look
like a happy person so I would actually
want to hero strong so um but you know
this is one of those words like I don't
think it's good but I give it a lot of
credit for what I tried to do at that
time period where a movie like this
really would never fly uh you know to
make a Casper the Friendly Ghost and
make him like the cartoon nice and
friendly and make the the cousins you
know just sort of these dumb idiotic
jerks like blame he makes the Care Bears
look like fucking chass
I um I just not had like I I'm sorry I'm
a I think I've met one person in my life
who likes Casper and it's my aunt yeah
who hates all other cartoons what she
likes Casper oh and don't you like any
parrot tunes did you watch any cartoons
growing although she likes because the
cartoon is dead I liked Casper the
Friendly Ghost and we were like doors
fucking really like I just Casper's the
one that just I just hated Casper to
begin with so then just the idea of
making a cast for the Friendly Ghost
movie like when I when like they
announced it that they were doing it I
was like ah no I think it's one of those
things where it's like I was just
starting to I was trying to sort of get
out of like those been like I think
neutrals 3 came out that time and that's
like you know I think I'm kind of done
with some of this kiddy stuff and
everything and so I saw it bad
I saw Casper I was like maybe this will
be like the first Ninja Turtles like
it's kind of crazy but maybe it'll work
it didn't quite but I serve respected
for the same angle that they're taking
this ridiculous idea and they're gonna
try and do stuff that you would normally
think would work I just realized
something why did I see it uh I don't
know that's bright nothing else out
there okay can I get maybe you wanted to
see it and I'm just like well whatever I
think it was like morbid curiosity we
could have been more be curious I am
like literally
like critics liked it at the time - you
know there at you say no nose was pretty
good like Cisco neither liked it I won't
say a Time magazine like justice like
okay anybody just tried to think back I
was like what what said stay brought me
into chaos yeah you're older so maybe uh
out of here Jan I remember that I liked
it I remember not like to get back man
but we walked out of there I'm air we
really made fun of the ending with the
with the white bag because we are like
okay this is this is pretty stupid
hybrid we were alive she will be better
than hold on I are you we're gonna get
kicked out because we were like laughing
so hard yeah no I do i do cameraman we
were a little pricks yeah I know we were
even bad bad we went to put Jack no like
we were just getting into this shoe
science theater so it's like we can do
this - I like real little assholes uh I
wanted to miss D it at the time I I
don't know but I'm like yeah I just
something doesn't like why the fuck I
thinks the same reason we saw bad name
Robin it was just morbid curiosity I'd
like to just add um but no for what it
was I still don't think it works but
like I said I really am kudos to the
filmmakers we're trying to do what they
were trying to do and in some areas
actually working like it does look very
nice uh you know I like that they try to
make the green on a dude at present but
it best failed experiment like they just
didn't succeed in anything not just
bring it to see well it took that risk
but a I at least had better payoff and
Casper did die hey you don't ever say I
had better payoff than anything
that's the remember the ending of that
movie he never had at that don't know
I'm not just talking about I'm saying
though the rest of the film know the
rest of Casper you're like yeah I really
I felt like I got something out of that
uh I would still like I said I would
argue that some of those scenes were
like I guess I do remember where he's
talking about dying and he's trying to
remember it in the memory and stuff and
as like for this big cartoony white
marshmallow to say this and to act I've
always got yes no I don't want every
done okay see I can't take it seriously
I'm just like it's Casper but no you got
to you got to complicated it got I can
we could say the right Wells was risky
to do a Casper cancer
drama but it's still like not gonna work
cats purr and that's when I died of
leukemia like it's still thought it
doesn't work
I like the machine that just brings
people back to life oh so you just kind
of cured death oh I got a movie no
whenever you get to the actual story
it's really dumb but like I thought it
had some nice scenes in it um but yeah
like I said I think I I have more
respect for what was trying to do I
don't think it worked but I thought some
parts did um because this film is a file
we found out after we reviewed it like
it it's got a following oh shit it does
yeah no I never really don't have you
said everyone's gonna get so all the
scenes I do like the review but now it's
from rod rather hate you probably guilty
as you know cuz my cells gonna review it
everybody was like hey no that's a good
movie you hush up I was like you're
defending Casper really like as good
you're defending Casper you're gonna put
you know hey wait a second you're
defending chaos no I I'm not saying it's
good I'm saying that I am respectful I
was trying to do and I like certain
elements of it I don't think uh no but
for me to get that out of Casper at all
I think it's impressive eh no idea this
is a minute following you are so bold
and you this is a trap this is
entrapment
it's much combat all over again don't we
the next one will call you all pussies
again bring it all back to me um but no
yeah I think it's our thoughts on the
movie um send all angry eight layers to
rub and yeah you know what um there's
things that that you don't like that
people like no no there's not I like
what every person out there likes I've
done the math I've actually asked every
person statistically I've done I'm Jalen
gesture reminded histah cailli and funny
for a second email
just a reminder he is also a new drag me
to spider-man 3 and X 3 and Batman
Forever and claimed they were all better
than the original
I did not find they were better than
your video I did not hesitate
and I yes and I was like twelve years
old when I saw Batman Forever blows your
excuse for spider-man 3 and X 3 because
number two you so spun it X 3 as an
x-men fan because you'll run a bigger
x-men fan than me and I realize it was
shit as the films aren't still stupid
films I'm like okay we're finally at
least doing something in these fields
now the time record my work here is done
you're a monster
who doesn't like Casper